who lay care podcast we got my guy jay
mills in here man welcome back welcome
back my god uh yo you came here to rap
so you know yeah man you're pretty good
at that don't call now
don't call now out right now available
on our platforms let's go man hit that
beat the blind stairs of a million pairs
of eyes looking hard but won't realize
that they will never slump
all of my suits is custom tailored i
caught my second winning all my haters
caught the vapors
let me keep that going while these bars
leave my crew got the juice and i handle
my biz at the marquee look with this
slick talk i'm with a guard b i'ma get
my books no matter what my dell cards be
call a spade a spade and connect the
dots these [ __ ] talking like they back
but they was never hot and they owned
her respect they never got i've been a
legend [ __ ] my resume gonna speak for
me before i check a [ __ ]
and in all honesty i already did what i
came to do all my visions became true
but i ain't living in the past i'm
living in the now they inquiring about
my style i get it from my town harlem
architect and i built it from the ground
friendship is deeper than handshakes and
bigger than a pound look i gotta get it
now i'm on some urgent [ __ ] these [ __ ]
out here living through they throwback
thursday pics them old flicks when they
was balling in cold whips them old
kingpin stories on how they sold bricks
i gotta get it cause my foresight is
vivid rolex and change vintage but my
aura futuristic white cherry gelato got
me feeling terrific blatant with what i
say so never gotta say to be specific
fly [ __ ] from ny they hate but check my
resume is always my reply i came in
talking my [ __ ] and imma talk it till i
die and ain't no mumble in my madness
when i speak my value i'm high so can
you hear me [ __ ] i'm clearly not
them others that these [ __ ] next like
winter stars yearly [ __ ] hope
you fully understand me don't just give
me [ __ ] sign still and delivered
some silly [ __ ] i hit from any
angle you'll get dismantled and mango i
will walk your favorite rapper like a
[ __ ] cocker span you when i [ __ ] i
[ __ ] a while and use a waist for grip
and handle throw her back and forth as
if i'm trying to loop and stretch and
sample you hype and get involved you
scared them get a dog long as i take
care they family i got killers that's
gonna take care of that charge that's on
god
i told you man i told you man
jay mills he was like yo you sure you
want me or not
i'm nice yo j mills cause they show you
another beat i said i'm nice hey man
listen i'm nice
right now don't call now bill don't call
now man go go go go run it up rest in
peace to the greats too rest in peace to
everybody yeah for sure that was crazy